[Music]  with more people traveling for the first  time since the shutdowns the better  business bureau is sending out a warning  don't get scammed out of your dream  vacation the bbb officials say they've  seen thieves pretending to be hotel  staff calling people to confirm  reservations  and getting personal information as well  as a payment  now if you're booking a vacation rental  watch out for listings  of homes that aren't for rent or they  just simply don't exist  a lot of different records out there  where you can check whatever state it is  and to see who owns that residence  see if the names are matching up see if  this sounds like the right person  also do a google search the property  even exists  also beware of free and unsecure wi-fi  connections at hotels and airports  experts say it makes it easy for hackers  to get into your system  and take your personal information